غدا الجمعه اول ايام عيد الفطر المبارك
عوده الاشتباكات في السودان وحديث عن
تمديد الهدنه
90 قتيلا في حادث تدافع في صنعاء
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
اقدم لكم هذه النشره في اخر يوم من شهر
رمضان المبارك حيث اعلنت المحكمه العليا
في السعوديه ثبوت رؤيه هلال شهر شوال
ليكون بذلك يوم غد الجمعه الموافق 21 من
ابريل اول ايام عيد الفطر السعيد وكذلك
اعلنت عدد من الدول العربيه والاسلاميه
ثبوت رؤيه هلال شوال فيما قال مركز الفلك
الدولي ان 7 دول اعلنت ان السبت هو اول
ايام عيد الفطر ومن بينها اندونيسيا
وماليزيا وسلطنه بروناي لعدم ثبوت رؤيه
الهلال مساء اليوم نتمنى لكم بعيدا مباركا
وكل عام وانتم بخير
الى السودان وبعد ساعات على بدء سريان
هدنه هشه في البلاد افاد مراسل العربيه
بتجدد الاشتباكات وتبادل اطلاق النار في
محيط القصر الجمهوري بالخرطوم فيما رصد
تحليق كثيف للطيران الحربي للجيش في سماء
الخرطوم بحري بدورها ردت قوه الدعم السريع
بمضادات ارضيه ضد طائرات الجيش
الى ذلك اعلنت مصادر في قياده الدعم
السريع انها مستعده لتمديد الهدنه لتشمل
عيد الفطر فيما لم يرد الجيش بعد على هذه
الدعوه هذا في مقالات منظمات الصحه
العالميه انها رصدت مقتل 330 شخصا واصابه
ثلاثه الافئتين اخرين
في حادثه ماساويه قتل واصيبه اليمنيين في
حادثه تدافع اثناء التزاحمهم لاستلام
معاناه ماليه مقدمه من احد التجار داخل
مدرسه في صنعاء ووفقا لاخر احصائيه اودت
الحادثه بحياه تسعين يمنيا على الاقل
واصيب نحو اكثر من 300 بينهم 50 في حاله
خطيره مراسل وكاله قال ان الحادثه وقعت
داخل مدرسه معين حيث تجمع المئات لتلقي
مساعدات فيما قال شهود عيان ان اطلاق نار
من قبل عناصر حوثيين ادى الى التدافع
بعد تكرار حوادث رصد مناطيد واجسام طائره
مجهوله في سماء الولايات المتحده قالت
شبكه سينان ان السلطات الامريكيه تتعقب
اكثر من 650 حاله محتمله لما يسمى
بالاجسام الطائره المجهوله باحثه عن تفسير
لها مدير المكتب المختص بمراقبه تلك
الشواهد بالبنتاجون قال ان النصف تلك
التقارير منحت الاولويه لانها اظهرت
معلومات مثيره للاهتمام بحسب المسؤوله
الامريكي مضيفا انه سيتم بحث ما اذا كان
هناك دور صيني في تلك الحالات ومستبعدا
احتمال وجود اجسام طائره قادمه من الفضاء
بعد اكثر من عامين ونصف على وفاته اعلنت
السلطات الارجنتينيه انها ستحقق مع اشخاص
متهمين بالتسبب بوفاه اسطوره كره القدم
الارجنتينيه دياغو مارادونا محكمه
ارجنتينيه وجهت الى ثمانيه عاملين في قطاع
رعايه الصحيه تهمه الاهمال وعدم الفعاليه
في علاج لاعب بوكا جونيوز
تقارير بان المحاكمه لن تبدا حتى العام
المقبل وبانهم قد يواجهون حكما بالسجن ما
بين ثمانيه الى 25 عاما وكان مارادونا قد
توفي عن عمر يناهز 60 عاما في نوفمبر 2020
بعد خضوعه لجراحه في المخ
[موسيقى]